[Musique]
c'est le paradoxe alors qu'on s'inquiète
pour le centre ville
rarement les grues auront été aussi
nombreuses dans le ciel de montréal
lancé avant la pandémie
c'est au résidentiel qui poussent un peu
partout changeront radicalement la ligne
d'horizon de la ville et vont attirer
des milliers de résidents les nouveaux
édifices comme le 628 saint jacques est
juste à côté le victoria sur le parc
auront 36 et 54 étages et offrirons 700
unités de condos le sujet sur saint jean
puis il est vendu à 80 % donc et les
gens avaient déjà fait leurs dépôts donc
on se considère chanceux sur une
permutation au broc de bonnes nouvelles
pour la vitalité du centre ville à
l'heure où les signes de ralentissement
du marché immobilier commence à
apparaître en raison de la pandémie des
vannes et charles-antoine habite rue
mcgill depuis cinq ans le centre ville
de montréal ça représente
l'activité la culture joie de
villeurbanne le restaurant le café il
louait et souhaitait devenir
propriétaire après avoir pensé habiter
le futur victoria sur le parc
la découverte du télétravail à modifier
leurs projets il déménage dans westmount
cet hiver maintenant que mon travail
rendu à la maison ça me ça me permet
d'être un petit peu plus portable donc
nous avons décidé d'aller plutôt vers
une maison à étage avec intérêt un
exemple parmi d'autres car si
l'immobilier se porte encore bien dans
la région le centre ville lui connaît
une baisse de popularité ya pas eu de
rebond des transactions au centre ville
au contraire au cours des trois derniers
mois la donc du mois de juin au mois
d'août
on a connu une baisse des transactions
cet été il y a eu 20 % moins de ventes
que l'été dernier dans l'arrondissement
ville-marie et le nombre de propriétés
annoncé a augmenté de 59% par rapport à
c'est une dégradation qui pourrait
s'accélérer au cours des prochains mois
si si c'est la situation perdure le
marché demeure toutefois favorable aux
vendeurs
le prix médian des achats s'est chiffré
à 442000 dollars en hausse de 11 % en un
an
c'est la première phase
1er lot papier de femmes laurence
vincent et coprésidente du groupe prével
qui souhaitent construire jusqu'à 2000
unités d'habitation au pied dont jacques
cartier elle espère que la pandémie ne
changera pas ses plans ce qu'on aime
c'est la prévisibilité donc là
évidemment on a beaucoup d'incertitude
face au futur
plus de 70% des 300 premières unités du
projet sont actuellement réservées
malgré l'insécurité actuelle de la
population et le télétravail en hausse
elles restent optimistes pour le
centre-ville et j'en prends traîne un
peu plus de temps pour prendre leur
décision parce qu'eux aussi ont une
certaine incertitude mais à ce qu'on
voit les ventes se poursuivent
peut-être qu'il ya certaines personnes
qui croient moins actuellement
peut-être que il ya des gens qui vont
quitter montréal mémorial reste trop
attirant pour sa densité son
effervescence
l'activité qui existe et qui est
résistera d'autant plus dans les
prochaines années
je les dernières sont avait répondu non
ce que moi je demeure convaincu que non
les bonbonnes l'état français vont
s'adapter
les bons résultats font aussi vont
réaliser qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire
au rang des environnements secure et des
intérêts en attendant broccolini a
retardé d'un an un important projet
résidentiel qu'il a ici coin sherbrooke
et guy question de suivre l'évolution du
marché
tout le monde espère que la deuxième
vague qui vivent commencer sera la
dernière de l'ouragan
jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
m'ont rien